waiting
i just spoken for some time with
president zlinski of ukraine
i told him as i have each and every time
we've spoken the united states stands
for the people of ukraine
and they're bravely as they greatly
fight to defend their country and they
are doing that
as putin continues as merciless assault
the united states and our allies and
partners continue to work in a locked
step
to ramp up the economic pressures around
putin under further isolate russia and
the global stage later today together
with other nato allies in the g7 canada
france germany japan
the united kingdom as well as the
european union we're going to jointly
announce several new steps to squeeze
putin and hold him more even more
accountable for his aggression against
ukraine
i want to speak to a few of those points
today first
each of our nation is going to take
steps to deny the most favored nation
status to
russia our most favored nation's status
designation
means two countries
have agreed to trade with each other
under the best possible terms
low tariffs
true barriers trade
and the highest possible imports allowed
in the united states we call this
permanent normal trade relations pntr
it's the same thing
revoking pntr for russia is going to
make it harder for russia to do business
with the united states
and doing it in unison with other
nations to make up half of the global
economy will be another crushing globe
to the aggression of congress already
suffering very badly from our sanctions
and i want to thank speaker pelosi
leader mccarthy leader schumer and
mcconnell and senators wiseman crapo
representative neil and brady for their
bipartisan leadership on this and the
congress
i would like to offer a special thanks
to speaker close who has been a strong
advocate for revoking pntr and who
agreed to hold off on that in the house
until i could line up all of our key
allies to keep us in complete unison
unity among our allies is critically
important as you all know from my
perspective
many issues divided some moisture but
standing for democracy in ukraine
pushing russia's aggression should not
be one of those issues
the free world is coming together to
confront putin
our two parties here at home are leading
the way
with that bipartisan cooperation i'm
looking forward to signing the law the
bill revoking pntr
which is again most people think of his
most favored nation status
we're also taking a further step
abandoning imports of goods from several
signature sectors of the russian economy
including seafood vodka and diamonds and
we're going to continue to squeeze
pruning
the g7 will seem to dry russia the
ability to borrow from leading
multinational institutions such as the
international monetary fund and the
world bank
putin is an aggressor he is the
aggressor and putin must pay the price
he cannot pursue a war that threatens
the very foundations which he's doing
the very foundation of international
peace and stability and then asked for
financial help from the international
community
the g7 is also stepping up pressure that
we're targeting and we're increasing
coordination among the g7 countries to
target and capture their ill-forgotten
gains
they support putin
they steal from the russian people
and they seek to hide the money in our
countries they're part of that
kleptocracy that exists in moscow and
they must share the pain
of these sanctions
and
while we're going after these
super super yachts and vacation homes
and for hundreds of millions
millions of dollars we're also going to
make it harder for them to buy high-end
products manufactured in our country
abandoning the export of luxury luxury
goods to russia
they're also the latest steps we're
taking but
they're not the last steps
and as i said the beginning of all these
steps we're going to hit proven hard
because the united states and our
closest allies and partners are acting
in
the
unison
of our sanctions now export control is
crushing the russian economy
ruble has lost more than half its value
tell me it takes about
200 rubles one dollar these days
moscow's stock exchange has been closed
for fully for two weeks because they
know the moment it opens it will
probably collapse
credit rating agencies have downgraded
russia's government to junk status
this economy junk status
the list of businesses international
corporations live in russia is growing
by the day
we're also continuing to close
corporations with allies and partners to
make sure that with close cooperation we
continue to have ukrainian people are
are able to defend their own nation
the united states has set more than one
billion dollars in security assistance
occurring over the last year
including
anti-armor and anti-air capabilities
taking out tanks and planes and
helicopters
with new shipments arriving every day
we in the united states are also
facilitating significant shipments of
security assistance from our allies and
partners to ukraine and the humanitarian
front we're working closely with the un
and humanitarian organizations to
support the people of ukraine who have
been displaced by the violence in the
grant providing we're providing tens of
thousands of tons of human supply and
you are using humanitarian supplies
food water and medicines
coming by a truck and train every single
day
yesterday in poland vice president
harris harris announced an additional 53
million dollars in additional
humanitarian support to ukraine
that brings the total humanitarian
assistance to 107 million dollars in
just two weeks
we joined this effort by moore with more
than 30 other countries for providing
hundreds of millions more
and last night
a great credit to congress passed the
bipartisan spending bill
and included an additional 13.6
billion dollars
in new assistance to the ukrainian
people
i look forward to signing down
immediately
i also want to be clear though
we will make sure ukraine has weapons to
defend against an invading russian force
we will we will send money food and aid
to save the ukrainian people
and i will welcome ukrainian refugees we
should welcome them here with open arms
they need access
and we're going to provide more support
from ukraine
we're going to continue to stand
together with our allies in here send
unmistakable message
we'll defend every single inch of nato
territory of the full might of the
united and galvanized nato
we will not fight a war against russia
in ukraine
direct confrontation between nato
and russia is world war iii
something we must strive to prove
but we already know putin's war against
ukraine will never be a victory
he hoped to dominate ukraine without a
fight he failed helped to fracture
european resolve he failed helped to
weaken the transatlantic alliance he
failed helped to split apart american
democracies in terms of our positions he
failed
the american people are united the world
is united and we stand with the people
of ukraine we will not let autocrats and
would-be emperors dictate the direction
of the world
democracies are rising to meet this
moment
rallying the world to the side of peace
in the sight of security
we're showing our strength and we will
not falter
god bless all of you god bless ukraine
and god bless our troops
president biden president biden your
white house has said that that russia
may use chemical weapons or create a
false flag operation to use them what
evidence have you seen showing that and
would the u.s have a military response
if putin does launch a chemical weapons
attack i'm not going to speak about the
intelligence but but uh russia would pay
a severe price
would the u.s would the u.s send troops